one of the good things in knockdown is
people have been able to send you
pictures of their cooking and basically
they send gordon picture their cooking
in the hopes that he'll sort of online
shout at them
so efforts here's an example someone
said uh pretty sure this is the best
poached egg in
a noodle soup you'll see all day gordon
replied
looks like toxic scum in a stagnant pool
they punched the air when they got there
well anyway some of our virtual audience
what they've done is they've
sent us pictures of their latest kitchen
creations
so uh gordon we'd like you to give them
just a little verbal one-liner
but be as cool as you like because they
want that's what they want okay first it
was paula booth
where's paula is she's going to zoom out
to us oh there's paula lovely
this is what paul has made paula made
haggis nachos
[Laughter]
nachos come on you've managed to piss
off the mexicans and the scots
in one dish congratulations paula well
done
uh rachel tindall let's see if we can
find rachel tindall oh there she is
hi rachel hi hi she's busy booking mini
cabs but quickly let's do this
she's she's baked a victorious sponge
victoria sponge no no no rachel i can
see two puddings there there's a
victoria sponge
and a large spotty dick
you were attempting fate with that uh oh
well done victoria
okay who's up next inga linklater
where's singapenga hi inga
inga it says here has created a baked
alaska see what you think gordon
baked alaska no it's like you've
cremated it the saving grace is it looks
like there's a wreath there so
egg white egg whites your donut
congratulations
well done and finally uh herman
herman stein oh there you are
hi wow are you in south africa now
oh excellent and you've created a
sausage bry
the traditional south african sausage
bride there you go feast your eyes on
that gordon
no offense but it looks like you just
curled one out on a plate
[Applause]
[Music]